Oh
diagnostic pelvic laparoscopy is used to
examine the internal organs of the
pelvis in an effort to identify a
specific problem you might be advised to
undergo diagnostic pelvic laparoscopy if
you have pelvic pain or a mass and
abnormal accumulation of fluid or
difficulty becoming pregnant
these may be caused by endometriosis
tubal pregnancy an ovarian cyst or tumor
scarring from pelvic infections or other
conditions
laparoscopic techniques require only
tiny keyhole incisions or puncture
wounds and the recovery period is much
shorter and more comfortable when you
arrive at the hospital for your
procedure an intravenous line will be
started and you may be given a sedative
to help you relax
pelvic laparoscopy is done under general
anesthesia which will put you to sleep
for the duration of the operation a
breathing tube will be temporarily
inserted through your mouth and into
your throat to help you breathe during
the operation a catheter will also be
placed in your bladder to drain your
urine
an uncomplicated diagnostic laparoscopy
may take as little as 30 to 60 minutes
your surgeon will gain access to the
interior of your pelvis by using a sharp
instrument called a trocar to make a
small half-inch opening or port just
below your navel or umbilicus carbon
dioxide gas will then be pumped through
this umbilical port to puff up your
abdomen so its contents can be viewed
more easily next your surgeon will
insert the laparoscope through the
umbilical port images from its camera
are projected onto a video monitor in
the operating room your surgeon will
carefully examine your pelvic organs and
tissues looking for signs of disease
that might explain your symptoms
he or she may create other ports through
which instruments can be slipped these
additional instruments are used to move
organs out of the way for better viewing
or to perform operative procedures such
as removing scar tissue taking biopsies
or draining abnormal fluid when the
laparoscope and other instruments are
removed a special gas valve is left in
place briefly to allow all the carbon
dioxide to escape from the abdomen the
keyhole incisions are closed with just a
few sutures or staples and then covered
with bandages after your surgery your
breathing tube will be removed and you
will be monitored in the recovery area
your catheter will be removed shortly
thereafter and you will be given pain
medication as needed your intravenous
line will come out when you can drink
liquids most patients are released
within a few hours of the procedure